que la tercera sea la vencida
seria de la gente decente con ese
objetivo se presenta de nuevo a la
presidencia de Paraguay Efraín alegre el
abogado de 60 años es la punta de lanza
de la alianza liberal de Centro
izquierda la concertación que busca
poner fin a la hegemonía del partido
Colorado hoy el enemigo de la democracia
en el Paraguay no es ningún partido no
es el partido Colorado nosotros estamos
enfrentando al dinero sucio al dinero de
la ilegalidad al dinero del crimen
organizado este dinero es el que hoy
pone en peligro nuestra
institucionalidad al frente del partido
liberal radical auténtico enarbola la
justicia social el desarrollo energético
y del campo pero sobre todo la lucha
contra la corrupción institucional que
asegura fue la que lo llevó a prisión
durante tres semanas hace dos años
acusado de adulterar documentos de
gastos de su campaña para las de 2018
cuando se quedó a sólo tres puntos de
lograr la presidencia Esto es lo que
dijo en una entrevista con France 24
también vamos a crear una secretaría que
es la secretaría para recuperar y
devolver al pueblo lo robado desde
entonces no solamente ellos este dejan
el gobierno sino que además tienen que
recuperar este lo que se ha robado
Durante este tiempo en materia de
asuntos internacionales alegre promete
restablecer las relaciones con el
gobierno venezolano preservar la
integración de mercosur avanzar en
acuerdos con la Unión Europea así como
revisar las relaciones de su país con
Taiwán dado que Paraguay es el único
país de Suramérica que reconoce su
soberanía nosotros tenemos que tener
relaciones con todo el mundo porque
dejaríamos de tener con Venezuela
por discrepancia en su modelo político
bueno esas son cuestiones que desde
luego nosotros este creemos que se deben
este tratar en Venezuela
resolverlos pero no dejar de tener
relación al contrario si podemos ayudar
en la consolidación de la Democracia de
Venezuela pero debiéramos estar ahí
Efraín alegre se presenta por primera
vez con una mujer como su fórmula
soledad Núñez y propone una paridad
institucional de llegar al poder una
victoria opositora el domingo que
rompería con El dominio prácticamente
total del partido Colorado en las
últimas seis décadas